[Music]
all right hello everybody bump it all
the way give me everything give me full
mics all right go full mic I'm Eric
that's Nick for everyone that's confused
about the game the game is actually
called getting over it it is a made I
believe by the same people that made the
game co-op and I called it rage-inducing
because even in the steam trailer this
it basically the developers said this
game is meant to hurt people and so
we'll get into it are mentally or
physically I think it's a mental thing
I'm let's start a new game you guys are
gonna see alright this is this is this
guy give us a little backstory what
what's going on really know what is that
this is this is who I'm controlling and
I can only control it with a mouse Nick
so I have to find a way to get through
it I think areas well while doing this
[ __ ] with only my mouse and so let me
let me preface this by saying I've never
been really good at these games one and
two since I know that I'm not very great
at these games Nick and because I know
that I'm not very good at these games
I'm kind of afraid I might not even make
it past the first level I believe in you
yeah I'm see we'll see so you gotta
climb this [ __ ] so who is this guy do we
know who this guy is
it's in the title it's Benny something
see like oh that's this is so stupid
okay tip of the tree solo stuck go back
sorry I have no idea what this is I only
found this this morning and I'm already
kind of regretting come on I will be Oh
feeling more intense than starting if
you deleted your homework the day before
it was jus and
I have or if you left your wallet at
home you have to go back to spending an
hour in the club if you want some money
at the casino and then put all your
winnings on red but it came up back if
you got your best shirt dry-cleaned
before a wedding and then immediately
dropped fruit on if you want an argument
with a friend and then later discovered
that they just returned to their
original view
starting over is harder than starting up
if you're not ready for that like if
you've already had a bad day
then what you're about to go through
might be too much feel free to go away
and come back I'll be here
I actually know oh all right so I'll be
monitoring chat YouTube there's going to
be three minutes and ten seconds yeah
good good luck to me that's wild the
best part about the description is like
the gameplay it's like anywhere from
three hours no no no no no don't push
yourself off anywhere from three hours
to infinity what if I never get past
this part can you die and it's back to
the beginning no like that's okay yeah
but you could get really far and then
push yourself back I think I need to be
way more precise than I am but I speak I
feel like you should be able to just
it's so close that one oh this guy has
great upper I also don't understand why
he has water in his pot like why does he
need that to wash himself slingshot if I
could if you put it there shot this is a
freakin Mouse Nick Oh
I'm Nick wait before your time here
mm-hmm I used to have this thing I used
to do a game spot called torture chamber
this is really reminding me of that
where I would play really hard games
that were very rage inducing is this
considered one of those Oh OOP says yes
because did I eat the wrong money today
or is this really happening this is
happening this is happening this is real
oh that's true he has a hammer just chop
the tree down
I wish oh that was the play I know right
have you tried this really bad oh yes
all right there we go
taste on his way he's on his way okay
we're getting a lot of whole a lot of
suggestions
Oh Oh get your ass up there I think you
gotta just swing it just yeah go four
and then quickly try to grab the tree
[Music]
Natan says you can put the hammer under
yourself and then jump it to gain height
ya know so that must be stuck in front
like water nice please stay don't ya
I don't yeah that's good don't fine
that's good that's good Oh easy
latch onto it alright alright nice
thanks for coming with me on this what
is this understand if you have to take a
break at any point just find a safe
place to stop and quit the game don't
worry I'll save your progress
always I'll even you mistakes nice oh no
ouch to a free game that came out in
2002 sexy hiking the author of that game
was Jesu a mysterious Czech designer who
was known at the time as the father of B
games B games a rough assemblages of
found objects and they're often too
rough and unfriendly to game on yeah
they're built more for the joy of
building them than his college products
what's this I see people are talking
about the Infinity Gauntlet one of the
old running jokes was that someone would
hit me when I failed I won't hit him so
getting on that to break in a certain
way embodiment of a B game
I don't it's built almost in parts and
it's one of the most unusual and
unfriendly games of its time in it
your task is simply to drag yourself up
a mountain with a hammer that act of
climbing in the digital world or in real
life has certain essential properties
that give the game it's the player is
constantly unremittingly in danger of
falling and losing everything it's funny
do you realize that we might never get
that high cuz I don't know how I got up
there to begin with Nick Wow I feel for
you do you know that was
this is it this is the torture chamber
reboot so by the way this game's not
actually out yet it was in the humble
monthly so if you're subscribing to that
you you got access to that into the game
I was able to get from crisper air who
is knows enough to let me do this to
myself thank you Chris
but it comes out December the stay clean
so you get the only controls here are me
yes or it's a trackpad but same thing
can you jump or it's only no only push
myself so you can jump like that okay
okay okay but I'm terrible with like
nice matt is asking how much is the game
I have no idea there's no price in this
steam store damn no I don't want to go
that easy that was close a looks like
praxis 20 says this looks like the most
frustrating game yeah so as I prefaced
earlier if you don't want to say to
watch this I totally get it if you want
to stay for the rage that will probably
happen at some point
there's probably strategy that I'm not
employing though I feel like Nick yes
there anyone anyone who has maybe played
the game or watch them on you're
supposed to like you're supposed to like
you know you real nimble and like yeah
alright that was that was smooth you got
a couple it looks like where is it
Mohammed was saying you got to come and
take it nice and slow nice and easy
but it's this frustrating I can
understand no yeah he said no even he
said no hello what is this random
deviation help guys from okay okay okay
no no no nice nice alright alright
you're good you're good you're good
nice you've done this you've done this
you know what says yeah
I need a break ah take a little break we
got a little bit we got some advice here
I'll get some advice this is the
beginning so the only advice I can offer
is that you try to do wide swings with
your mouse to keep the hammer always
extended thank you is that Murdoch of
sorry if I butchered your name ah should
try the jump again here though let's see
yes Cameron wood is asking is this the
beginning on YouTube chef yep this is
the beginning
oops you it says coming soon where'd you
get it so it was a part of the Humble
Bundle it was humble monthly of October
you can't get any more if you weren't a
part of it
oh you have to wait till the December
release now so December releases when
it's actually coming out I'm so scared
Nick I'm so scared I don't want to fall
back down I you know what I believe in
you I'm gonna be the positive
reinforcement here and I think you're
gonna nail it and it's gonna be great
ready grab that coffee oh he just lost a
lot of progress that's a deep
frustration and real punch in the gut
I love it God why would you tell me that
like I didn't need that from him that
was a deep friendship frustration that
must be like a punch in the gut
thanks.thanks game so vexation gaming
which is asking what is the objective of
the game I think you're so just supposed
to climb is like climb [ __ ] I think I
think it's it's basically a side
scroller but Billy saying you called it
that he quit where you fell back down
that looked real tricky getting a lot of
haha
and some old man's the haha from that I
nightlight 3,000 says his advices quit
now so you don't suffer later
that's probably not a terrible a
suggestion but can't call it a rage
stream and no sorry about that wow this
guy talk ok that advice to try to keep
it extended is definitely the play or
nothing what is the play because you
definitely like latch on [ __ ] like the
fact that it's crossing this thing
doesn't really make yes but whatever Oh
Matt and YouTube chat says is this in
the convo for game of the year cuz it
should be
[Laughter]
this guy makes sounds like our own
Matthew s Pinelli
okay we're getting like sorta better at
this part but not really remember that
first time when I just got up there like
willy-nilly a lot of people are saying
it's very frustrating to watch I know
it's killing you
trust me I try to warn you guys ahead of
time that this is gonna be a frustrating
stream and I get it if you don't want to
stay around the best I can offer you is
that it'll be my rage or my success
you can stay for that or stay for the
guy and see what other stuff he says to
me as I fail this game yeah and also
this is we're playing on PC so today is
controlling the hammer with with the Oh
with the mouse it's not a it's not a
controller for those who thought it was
a controller happen again
keep on trying don't let it get to you I
feel like it's that is in there just
like Oh even more minutes to get you
yeah you know how to get good comments
that's fair that's fair that's fair
so goob said he's asked about our own
map española you sneak up on him when
he's like working on some kind of
editorial and you like hey Matt I need
something yeah it sounds like this guy
Oh
nightlight what's harder this or cuphead
oh I would argue this looks harder than
come bed oh nice okay you really have to
like jump yourself there yeah and they
get the jump and then watch on no just
my repertoire yet the jump in jump
jammer
it'd be like like like that we're like I
just got to be more Leon says you got to
get the pickaxe in the right position of
the tree underneath the shed
so I guess right yeah yes right there
nice Bob Jones wants to know is that we
call a failure is not the falling down
but the staying down Mary Pickford Bill
freestyler says doing taxes sounds more
fun than this game Oh Phil freestylin my
buddy a Phil you should be working
you're supposed to be working but I
appreciate that you're watching the
stream we need a cam on the mousepad
oh okay so I totally brought I totally
brought a web cam it's in my backpack
that or you'd have to just like take the
the you see our our camera yeah you have
to practice says I'll pop back in ten
minutes
schools don't suck at the beginning No
[Music]
when you get them leg upgrades
[Music]
it's gonna show me his patience no no
already already
we're not liking the sensitivity huh
kiha is right oops you write music ten
attempt I agree these are all good
strategies denying it but I know that I
know it is 100% of these watch out these
guys really I'd like to see them do this
[Music]
split the control to the mouse key fix
the keyboard there's there's only Mouse
[Music]
Wow
the Navy gamer claims he finished this
game and traded with zero
what's DFS nope
I tried mega I tried I tried to stay
calm do that first run first I don't
know I literally did this do it again
[Music]
doesn't work you have to hop that one
yeah see now I'm saying oh wait you just
[Music]
see I gotta get that ha ha okay
you got to get the pickaxe at the edge
of the tree which tree the one below the
shed I think he's nice right there yeah
good job okay we're taking it easy we're
taking a break we're taking a break
we're taking a break break that was
correct I didn't eat Thank You Leon FC
that was good that was good okay
this song is also over yeah it's gonna
play once I fall here all right how you
gonna do this you gonna try to push out
dude sometimes I feel like taking a
break might not have been the best idea
cuz I had all that momentum the momentum
all right a lot of positive
encouragement Bob Jones made it goob
whoo now you're not good ilex in the
YouTube chat says I've seen guys do work
in every game and it looks like this is
a struggle fest I think it is this is
just very difficult No are you good nice
nicely done I know I'm running out of
history yeah and I get yourself a little
break no no break would have no rain
the eyes no tears John that would you go
below the shed that's what you know yeah
I agree
that's why I'm like reaching the mouth
[Music]
[Music]
get your ass on the rock
nice easy easy okay now what I feel like
you want to put yourself on top of the
taller barrel yeah yeah okay that's
tough okay so there you are nice finesse
so now they want you to jump with the
hammer yes careful oh it's easy easy no
need to the cuff interactable why is the
goddamn cuff interactable it [ __ ] me
that was oh that was oh no that's not no
no no you're not
your ass is not going past the shed
this isn't this is a mistake
you know what yeah which way you've been
doing it before like that anyway when
you start sexy hiking down you it might
take you an hour to get over that tree
[Music]
boring the limits of your reach and your
strength trying to find a way up and
over and there's a sense of truth in
that lack of compromise most obstacles
and video game worlds are fake you can
be completely confident in your ability
to get through them once you have the
correct method or the correct equipment
or just by spending enough time in that
sense every pixelated obstacle and sexy
hiking is real sexy hi sexy Mikey well I
feel like you've got the shed down pack
now so I don't know we got lucky last
time hmm that is funny smithing the
YouTube chats and nice oh nice
[Music]
but what the hell are we supposed to do
up there you gotta just kind of yeah
yeah okay just get your ass up there
please I'm begging you
oh they're flipping the script on me
they're they're making me go the other
way I don't know how to roll those trash
cans oh my I'm so scared my my arm is
locked but I can't I don't want to let
go okay you know those things we're
gonna move okay
okay Wow
okay no reward and you climb till
spacesick so again what is the name of
this game what's getting over it getting
over it its name the game you are a man
half man half pot hot it's full of water
you have a hammer that you a hammer
slash pick you can kind of like use to
navigate this space but you can only use
your mouse Eric is that very high I
don't want to jinx it I don't know what
to do here I feel like you have to go to
the right but I like should see this you
see oh I feel like all that stuff is
gonna fall so you're gonna have to do it
twice
come on hop over there hop your ass over
there oh you see that they're saying
they're saying you got to do the jump
thing you got to push in and swing but
that's so difficult and that makes the
game uniquely frustrating but I'm not
sure jazz row intended to make a
frustrating game it's it's the
frustration and decision with an act of
his climbing and it's authentic to the
process of building a game about mind
Mel anything happened to me as I was Mel
here's a tip but have an idea for a new
ops and I would usually turn out to be
unreasonably hard but I couldn't bring
myself to make it easier it already felt
like my inability to get past a new
obstacle was my fault as a player rather
than as a builder imaginary mountains
build themselves from an if it's
deployment and it's our repeated
attempts to reach the summit that turns
those mountains into something real
no okay I know what I have to do but
this whole time I've been going this way
right with the mouse yes now I'm having
to go this way oh fricking with my mind
nice oh god what if like you think going
over it means we're starting over
yes I do I do that's why I would take
this as slow as you possibly can this is
scary cuz you know you know that rock on
the left sends you right back beginning
what do you think he's gonna say when we
fall all the way down he's gonna have
some words of encouragement that are
also just why okay okay what the [ __ ] is
this crevice what is this
you've them I think you have to break
those rocks when you're building a video
game world you're building with ideas
and that can be like working with quick
sets whoa you mold your ideas into a
certain shape that can be played with
and in the process of playing with them
they begin to harden and set until
they're immutable like rock what the
hell is that [ __ ] up there without
breaking it
it's just dividing freshmen I think
you're looking a step and you kind of
have to do like the mario thing okay
yeah yeah that a lot of people are
asking about the controls I turn this
down just know
oh no scary the controls are the pain I
feel now is the happiness I had before
that's the deal
CS Lewis oh come on we had all the
momentum we needed there's that coffee
cup you Matt says Eric your gameplays
giving me chest pains shiz up so how do
you goo biz asking how do you jump I'm
using the momentum of the swings to like
push push yourself push myself in Mon on
a piece above all earthly dignities a
still in quiet conscience William
Shakespeare I can try to move this
camera so we can see your hand if you
want yeah well you can do is go full
game you cannot now believe that you
will ever feel better yeah it's not true
oh you're sure to be happy again and
knowing this truly believing it will
make you less miserable now Abraham
Lincoln ah Thank You square one guys me
I can do it
might be a good time to take a break
here hold on I'll do it
Eric is currently adjusting the camera
so we can get a little bit of hand cam
going in the PIP I see that we've fallen
back to the bottom
all right he's got it he's got it all
right let's do this
game game ax up hill uh spit all right
now you get to see Eric's pain also
don't forget guys
gamespot we stream while eric streams
pretty much every single day at 11 a.m.
Pacific so go ahead and hit that
subscribe or the follow button so you're
notified when areas live
[Music]
[Applause]
we play a lot of huge games eating this
one getting over again if you guys have
any suggestions or tips for Eric go
ahead and throw them in the comments I'm
reading the YouTube and twitch like I
don't know for me it's like you know it
was probably like a proper way to play
yeah
[Music]
gets going like one like that
Marco says you can do it I believe this
game man why did that push him off light
light says my dad you can't handle this
thanks for stopping by though
a Cyberman the name of the game is get
was it
get over it is essentially Erica's fan
to get over this sprawling map with
nothing but a hammer slash pickaxe nice
break little break rank
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
people really want your old show thank
you oh we had a couple classic episodes
being shared
give me the momentum man hey sleeve done
all right don't forget god I don't go to
the left here my wrist hurts so bad how
do we get up here oh did we do the jump
you jump so you gotta do the jump here
and then you grabbed and then it kind of
looks like it's it's locked up there but
it's not you gotta have to shimmy
between those two rocks nice all right
so you gotta get up in there and oh the
lights the light fixtures you want to
grab on to the lights apparently okay
all right here we go so do we jump up
onto it
I'm not sure trial and error I don't got
the skill for this me this this looks
very difficult the rest of it is you
know why is this a thing why do we have
to shoot this with a pot man say well
there's another way to do this knows and
you think that job you're gonna jump to
get onto this guy though no no thank so
much of that guys is there to try to
push you back you've done this pot
before you know what's possible just do
what you did the fish shut up I didn't
do this part never did in yeah and now
if you jump there you're sliding bro
this is tough no this is tough thanks
Cameron Wood says jump from the rock
make sure the pit is underneath you
also they said you have to jump quickly
to get the momentum
you gotta hook onto the lights this is
Leon FC Devil's chimney his struggle is
real do-do-do-do-do
this is a good place to like practice
the jump though gubin the twitch at says
my wrist hurts from watching the tap I
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
DK wiser going back down the objectives
to go up good question
James says you can't do it
[Music]
why stop stop doing it that was a little
scary but yeah you guys don't forget
lots of streaming here at GameSpot 11:00
a.m. Pacific every day
every weekday that is so go ahead hit
the subscribe button hit the like button
hit the follow all those all those
subscribes and follows will help Eric
succeed in his journey to get over it
also if I noticed the subscription stuff
I'll give you a little shoutout
all right good job good job this is the
devil's what was it the devil's crevasse
or something like that they call it I
believe someone summoning the chat I
don't know who it was but somebody
played and they know - out in the forces
Nick grab the Infinity Gauntlet to
motivate him with the fear of pain hello
bukhari sorry if I butchered it well
torture to start your Monday
The Devil's Canyon Devil's chimney so
goop says this is gonna be a weekly
thing right cuz he's all in oh wow that
was scary
eric has gone very quiet
alright ramireddy will bring need a
break stretch it my pressures climbing
Chester I'm watching this I know you you
wear one of those wrist braces do we
that was for my
mark over here get on the job but get on
the rocket jump it's not as easy as it
looks
I would love to do that
[Music]
re Mon YouTube says it took someone on
Twitch eight hours palms be sweaty my
spaghetti the truth mom's spaghetti feel
you you and me bro we just got to get up
this damn Devil's Canyon or whatever the
hell it is Wow Matt and YouTube says he
saw a speedrun of four minutes and 21
seconds let's go I don't understand how
that's possible I could hours between
eight and four over there wild okay
nicely done
gravity okay alright so Eric you've been
going for about let's see 45 minutes or
so has it really been that long
how's it feel how's it feel I feel awful
right now dude I feel pretty good that
we got up this high but like I don't
know if I can like oh come on baby
how is it tree not in play
oh that's redonkulous at least we didn't
like at least we didn't get sent all the
way down Nick if we
send all the way down I think I would oh
dude that was awesome I believe I'm a
believer some people are saying that
maybe if you turn the sensitivity down I
like it's one of those things where I
feel like now that I'm like don't know
if I can replicate what I just did we're
uh we're really good at speedrunning
going the opposite direction
yeah oh
gube calling you out I bet you take it
well I don't know you'd have to ask
yeah I agree gosh he's getting a little
too old for this I'd like to see anyone
else in the office do this the only
other person I could see really
dominating this game Joey because Joey
loves really hard games all right so now
though
all right so I have to hop up dude I got
a pop up that trees not in play so
you're gonna have to god is this great
on the side and play though here yeah
I'm that rock that rock structure is in
play but like okay okay don't know how
we're gonna get enough momentum bring my
hammer down well how are you just
sitting there that's crazy I'm seeing on
the lamp row my pot is on the lamp don't
fall trying to see if I can angle this
down to oh so that's what you're gonna
try do not stand at my grave and cry I
am NOT there oh we did not die Mary fry
Mary fry nope
to live is to suffer to survive is to
find some meaning in the suffering
Friedrich Nietzsche oh my god Friedrich
Nietzsche life is a mosaic of pleasure
and pain grief is an interval between
two months of joy peace is the interlude
between two wars
you have no rose without a thorn the
diligent picker will avoid the pricks
and gathered a flower Satya Sai Baba
these are some very encouraging quotes
[Music]
yes goob
we are back started from the bottom that
way you square one
oh but think think of like how much
struggling we had earlier around this
area these quotes are very very lovely
pretty game also if you need to take a
break it's okay I've saved your progress
I feel like he's mocking you
sorrow is my own yard where the new
grass flames as it has flamed often
before but not with a cold fire that
closes around me this year William
Carlos Williams I'm not sure if I said
that right and YouTube just goes is Eric
trying to unlock all the points yes I am
I want to know what he's got to say for
me all right Robert
Alfred Greene good luck I'm gone I know
you've got it thanks you got it anyway
let's do this ooh
dee dee kane youtube says Bret Schumaker
apparently beat this somebody we should
call him for some Brad hot tip Brad Brad
beat this my gamer card really he said
but no he said only using a keyboard
which is missing you up you can mute me
in the settings yeah mature how do you
beat on the keyboard oh I was a nice
little run
I wanted to take Brad to do this what
anybody yeah yeah go straight to the
city this turns along now I'm trying to
get all the coats right yeah
quote unlocker this should be an Olympic
sport hot cauldron man a little music
woopsy doodle you think that need loot
box
maybe I hope so oh this is a good
question hey will you try to clear this
game on your own God why won't you hate
the [ __ ] and it's the bottom of the
canyon are huge now the commentator are
you now the narrator of this game you
got this you can do it
woopsy doodle I cannot imagine if I
really if someone said hey we're gonna
put you in a room you're not allowed to
leave this room until you finish this
game I think I might be distracting
myself with the with the mouse
[Music]
just let me get back there game yeah
that's right you know what Eric you're
doing great
because Raphael and YouTube agrees I I
would have quit at this point I would
have quit maybe first I'm exactly the
type of gamer he aimed this game at
frustrate well Joker's seven six nine
zero I didn't see the numbers and twitch
says so far what I've seen most people
it takes about 10 to 15 hours to beat
and they do multiple sessions or the
streamers just quit yeah I'm sure that's
the case I just want to get through the
Devil's gorge
dude Devils are gone what do you guys
think in the comments this is a very
difficult game in your gaming past
careers whatever you want to call it
what do you guys think is the most
difficult game you guys have played or
maybe like a specific part of a game
though it's really difficult Ninja
Turtles going through the water a pop
run rock wants to know what exactly is
the plot it's to just get over it get
over all these places fill freestyle
going to lunch now see you guys in the
same location in an hour
oh no we're probably gonna call it here
soon especially if I fall again
Oh Super Meat Boy yeah the gates
difficult so is a super rude bear if you
guys it's kind of like Super Meat Boy is
[Music]
Battletoads the speed bike part yeah
nicely done you're plugged into now is
that the time to ask okay
Matt and YouTube says I'm going on 20
years of gaming and it probably is still
cuphead cuphead is very difficult
yeah there's some there's some difficult
stuff in there because I haven't watched
it yet Joey did a had the opportunity to
talk to the the two brothers who made
cuphead and we have a feature up called
them how
cuphead was made and it goes into a
really in-depth da Joey's actually made
a couple of these videos you should
definitely check it out I want to be the
boss he's pretty hard too harder than
the guy run rocks is wondering are we
gonna live view it I am not sure if we
are the game comes out of December I
believe so I guess will you have to keep
an eye out for what this game review it
I don't think can make it from diabolos
the lights are fooled by the players
rage that's true
stay there
alright so trying to do here trying to
jump
what kind of jump to hook to the took
myself to the lantern then I got got a
hop on to the other lantern the top is
where I don't understand like there's
nowhere for you to you gotta use the
gravity to just like push yourself up
there I think and think by me thinking
about it it's like what's screwing up
here
I'm very impressed we get this far but
you got this far thanks this game will
become a meme
pull yourself forward nice
[Music]
this is tough so stressful this is tough
and it's the stress of that happening
that makes it worse Oh of all sad words
of tongue or pen the saddest I don't
think I don't think I can't I can't get
back up there was I will give you five
minutes to get back to the top
that was a sick jump lot a lot of lol's
in the comments as to be expected lulz I
didn't come into this room not expecting
some lol back to the beginning Wow lol
Oh
if you try to please audiences
uncritically accepting their tastes it
can only mean that you have no respect
for them andrei tarkovsky it's kind of a
theme wash dream a classic song born to
lose
[Music]
it says tasting to be very productive
later when you can't believe his hand as
Tay pushes on I'll once again remind
everyone that here at GameSpot Eric and
some the other guys like myself do some
streaming every day at every weekday at
lemonade and Pacific so go ahead and if
you're on YouTube hit the subscribe
button
five when we go live if you're on Twitch
the follow buttons to get those
notifications we love having you guys
the comments section asking for
suggestions just hanging out with you
guys it's super fun
yeah we play a lot of different games
some kind of smaller titles like this
one some big triple-a titles Eric is our
destiny expert so we got a lot of
guessing stuff coming up also for those
of you guys who were interested in Star
Wars Battlefront 2 we got a lot of
content coming in for that so keep an
eye out another another good reason to
subscribe
a lot of interesting things happening on
the microtransaction front with that
game the devs responded to the two
minutes left
[Music]
yeah so destiny stuff is coming soon I
don't got that spin I need don't hate
the player hate the guy yeah I agree
iced tea iced tea my man my man a hasty
down the pipeline I'm not sure how to
check in with Peter boy his Jam Bob
Jones has a destiny question Forte okay
they fix the faction for me no okay I
know all right here we go
the big finish the big finality of this
dream
nice
just so everyone knows - okay I had no
practice before reset and sat in this
room and tried skim so we should all be
very impressed okay
give me give me like 15 seconds okay all
right oh my wrist hurts so bad
all right okay there's no time to rest
like this no rest for the wicked for the
wicked here we go oh yeah when do you
get the leg upgrade good question this
guy is incredible upper body strength
dude he's ripped out of his mind I
believe
[Music]
what people are saying they're surprised
you haven't rage quitted he would never
do it for the stream
[Music]
what this struggle come on
I just want to try this stupid happy
person that yay , has passed 400,000
down votes now
Wow yay change something ei make your
game more like this one he knows he
knows to get on the rock I know but like
it's tough for me to get on the rock I
guess people are asking what was the a
comment I'm not sure exactly what it
said specifically but it had to do with
it taking about 40 hours of in-game
playtime and PAL front to in order to
you know gain one of the the leaders the
heroes that he is which is a lot of time
a lot of time especially for how many
heroes are in the game
I will say though Battlefront 2 is
beautiful it is a beautiful game but
their rationalization for in-game fences
bucks you got this
we're not stopping till you fall the way
back down what then I'm gonna purposely
view that no nice
how did you get on that little rock
earlier because I think that was the
game changer you kind of just kind of
pulled yourself
[Music]
no we you're rollin nice yes that is
Nick Emma's voice we do hello robert
how are you know you got this nice
little hooker well hook hook hook swing
action oh nice that was a that was a
little squeaker I was a little rough the
release date for this game number six
Inc is - okay December the sick unless
you know somebody that got it through
the humble monthly which it came out in
October so humble monthly October
release okay I need a break
little break my wrist hurts so bad this
is like carpal tunnel inducing alright
we got to try to get to this rock right
that when you were on it earlier you
were killing it we'd be killing me
Oh
Macari says try the other hand that
would be a brutal my left hand does not
have that you have to get your ass on
the rock
all right okay okay okay well push I
cannot pronounce your name in the twitch
app you can get it anytime from humble I
think no no you can't even grow you
can't anymore can you
they're saying you so can they think
it's part of the trove you get when
subscribing okay break on the rock god
are we far from the top anyone know do
we are hella far this is not even close
to the end of the game Oh have you
looked I have not seen when to the
sessions of sweet silent thought I
summon wow that's place past I sigh the
lack of many it's a game where you are
old woes new wail my William Shakespeare
sonnet that's it that's just go full
camera I don't want to see this game
anymore dude I don't
oh it doesn't work cuz oh it's a warning
as my Matson it's my fault
I don't really know realistically what
percent
this is a warm-up for the rest of the
game oh that's great great it's just a
warm-up all right
I couldn't even beat the warmup someone
clipped I don't know man F this game all
right thanks everyone for tuning in as
Nick mentioned earlier we are live every
day tomorrow
I believe we're actually gonna be able
to do Rocky League on switch I want to
say the devs might be in as well so
maybe we'll get a little salty runback
from way back in the day when we
challenged ionics and got our butts
handed to us probably still gonna get
our butts handed to us but stay tuned
for that tomorrow there may or may not
be destiny to stuff tomorrow normally we
do that every week as Nick mentioned
Wednesday's the lobby Thursday we're
gonna have Skyrim on switch
that should be fun and then Friday we
start extra life extra life is when we
stream for the kids we're doing 72 hours
across all our territories we're gonna
start at 24 hours here in the US the
charity our site is up I think someone's
gonna puss it on gamespot comm yeah so
if you want to contribute to the kids go
ahead and go there and put in your
donations already so yeah 24 hours here
then I think it's 24 hours in Australia
then 12 in UK then 12 back to us and
we'll wrap it up on that Sunday so if
you guys have some money to donate we'll
be playing games possibly doing some
stupid stuff this weekend someone in the
engineering pit said they already bought
the one chip challenge I know that
that's something that's been done on
giantbomb but hey if you want to pay for
someone on staff to eat a one chip
challenge which is like Carolina Reapers
and peppers
last year Nikki got its ghost peppers go
vote ghost pepper vodka no thanks
I'm sure it's got a couple things yeah
Epis leave right now anyways thank you
guys all for tuning in hit that outro
we'll see you guys next time thank you
guys for tuning in to getting over it
over the game I'm alive
[Music]
you